it's a romance it's a love story it's a
action and it's um on some level and
it's it's really a story about a humble
man of a good character and with a
troubled past you didn't pull any sorts
from any stones did you she might have
done something something bigger maybe
Sam Elliot is ready for war in the man
who killed Hitler and in the Bigfoot
right after his wildly acclaimed work in
a star is born I do want to talk about
your co-star Lady gaga have you gone to
her Las Vegas I knew I'd seen it just
saw a clip yesterday oh we're gonna go
we're gonna see both of her shows I saw
a clip yesterday when we went to the SAG
Awards and it was pretty amazing it was
Bradley getting up on stage singing
shower with her and I was just wishing
to be the
[Music]
I'd like to be a fly on the wall for a
Las Vegas trip with Sam Elliot so just
be really great I'm sure you got it I
used to go to Vegas back in the old days
a girlfriend I used to go to Vegas long
a long time ago
we saw a number of shows we stay at the
Flamingo Hotel but I'm looking forward
to going over there taking Kathryn in my
dark Leone it's Stephanie she's been
really good to all of us yeah I'm sure
they're Gaga fans so you're gonna have
it your girlfriend's house how bad ever
did for you long overdue round of
applause on your Oscar nomination I mean
50-year career
it just seems crazy that it's taken so
long but we're used to relying crazy
doesn't happen at all taking so long so
you were surprised by the nomination
yeah it was a surprise but you know it
I've never thought about Awards that's
not part of my world it's not when I
search for is not when I go after ya
it's the work really well your work
speaks for itself and that's why I
thought it was long overdue
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]